[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm link and i'm
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting uh we're going to do something
that we haven't done in a while and
we're going to go down the rabbit hole
yes yeah this is when we take like a
subject topic
and we've brought nothing we've brought
nothing except ourselves into this
and no holds barred we are
going deep into the rabbit hole based on
a topic that is generated let's link
arms and dive in
we're not
well i'll join you in the rabbit hole in
a second this is the last time that i
will say something about your glasses
these are my anything go glasses uh but
i just you know
you've made this decision
i am
coming to terms with it uh
i you you can do whatever you want
you sure it's your face
but i am looking at it
and uh i think i do just glasses i think
they're cool i think they're cool
glasses thank you man it's got you know
you got good
good fashion choice
i it
is the wise philosopher once said can't
nobody tell me nothing
okay i don't know who that was the wise
philosopher uh
it's the last thing i'll say
is that uh
you know there are going to be people
who
stumble upon this video
in other subsequent videos in which you
wear these glasses
and they will come to conclusions that
you then may have to either confirm or
uh deny
or steer them away from if people if if
if people want me to rest as can i put
them on for a second anything in there
yeah man let me just put them on for a
second just you'll see what's up just so
we'll see what's up
they're light
i'm just saying that's cool man i'm just
all i'm just saying is that i first of
all i can't see now i know what's
happened your left eye is not great your
right eye is okay i've beat you to it um
that's what you're saying you can't wear
these glasses well no no no no i'm not
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna wear these
glasses i'm in fact i keep thinking i'm
gonna have to get glasses and my vision
just keeps going so
um i think those look
just bomb ass on you man
too bad they're mine they do my question
is
if i wore these glas like what would you
say to me if i were if i was the one who
had worn these glasses first because
let's be honest
you're definitely the one who points
things out on people a lot more than i
right right let me give me a fashion
decision hey give me some time to think
about your question so i can come up
with an answer the exact same thing
you're saying to me give me my glasses
back
this is
but people are drawing conclusions about
me now
what conclusions are they drawing
does some black guy's got some bomb ass
taste man
i mean some people might be saying that
man he's got some balls to back it up
too
you think a guy rides a loud motorcycle
has got big balls
usually i think it's compensating for
something
i like the way these glasses look i like
the way these glasses feel i like the
way these glasses you don't have to
defend the choice of glass oh i'm not i
made that clear i am i'm establishing it
i told you this is the last time i'm
ever going to talk about them
you should get some man you know what
i'll get you a pair i'm going to get
sunglasses that you can't see my eyes
what are you gonna do about that see you
can see my eyes that's the great thing
about them yeah you can from some angles
there's a video version of this show
over on youtube if you're only listening
to this you can wait up we can wait six
days you can watch it on the earbiscus
youtube channel you can watch me
from behind my glasses we've heard that
the young kids
um
they prefer
to
watch
like they will not yes yes
tell are we right about this
we've been told
that that
the young people
have to see who's talking
i mean or else i guess they just don't
know whose talk i don't i don't
understand it because all the all the
podcasts on spotify are going to be
are going to be pushing for video that's
what that's what i'm hearing
no i do things while listening to
podcasts i'm driving i'm working out i'm
walking i walk to last night i didn't
listen to a podcast to listen to a book
but cool
i don't understand i what are they doing
while they're watching my bike i don't
watch people talk what are they doing
while they're watching
uh what are they doing getting another
layer of i mean we're kind of proving
their point right now another layer of
entertainment but what are they doing
right now because they're not just
listening or watching a podcast they're
also i'm also studying you can't do both
of those at the same time if you're
trying to do your homework and you've
got this on in the background first of
all you know what
yeah you should do that i'm i have split
interest here because i want people to
watch we need the views
but your education is important
you gotta focus on your freaking
schoolwork
now you gotta you gotta reward yourself
develop the ability to do what i can't
which is two things at once
listen to a podcast and study use
different parts of your brain like
divide it up i don't do it buddy can do
that do it so you what how are how do
you want to do it don't touch my
computer how do you want to do this i
can't let go now
uh
well we used to do a thing where like
there would be like something written on
a
envelope and we'd open it up but that
was just a waste of paper
so i've gone to
conversationstarters.com oh it looks
like a great website it's great graphic
design at the top conversation
starters.com this is like you you're
like really apprehensive on like your
first date and you like got conversation
starters.com down there below the table
at chili's you're kind of like looking
down yeah right like what are you
looking at oh just oh nothing just like
the time it was
it's time for me to start another
conversation completely unrelated to the
previous one
uh i also oh man i'm having so much fun
already i also
followed the glasses i was going to
capitalize my title dot com
what because when you search
uh capitalize random topic generator or
topic generator
capitalize my title what is that
it's the first one that comes up but it
just
i don't even understand like if i were
to go to
what it is just
what
dude that's an
x out of the ad do i need to teach you
how to but why is the internet no but
why is capitalize my no i clicked on the
i clicked on the home page
so now i'm at
capitalizemytitle.com
and it just says making title
capitalization easy
automatically capitalize and case
convert to title case oh
i
yeah that's great when you're just
writing stuff out and all the lowercase
and then you gotta like and you have a
really long title that you can't just
edit
like this is like a subtitle you've got
a subtitle that also but there's lots of
ads on i
i hate having to capitalize every word
in a title it's like it's exhausting
but if i could just paste it into a
website and then it spits it out and
then i paste that
that's a lot well a lot easier now you
can do that capitalize my title dot com
and also all right get some nikes based
on the ads
go to random generator because so but i
am going to use that capitalized but i'm
going to
conversation starters.com conversation
starters are like the
the big vibe the the big brother to
capitalize my title dot com okay i'm
going to generate a topic generate a
topic now we're not going to start
talking about this topic unless we both
agree that this is something we're
talking about but when we do
my vote is you just keep talking and you
see where the rabbit hole goes and if
you get to the bottom of that rabbit
hole maybe you start a new conversation
but maybe you curl up and die
what is the biggest priority in your
life right now
seriously
what's the biggest priority in my life
right now don't answer it don't even
begin talking about it it's a dumb
question
yeah what is your favorite dessert oh
what who do you think we are a couple of
guys
eat food on the internet
conversation starters.com don't take
don't ask that question on a date
because what if they don't have the
dessert at the restaurant what is it
what if chili's doesn't serve that
dessert right
what is this ama comprised of only
middle schoolers
what's your favorite dessert what did
you do on your most recent birthday
uh
man i don't remember
it's poolside
yeah i do
did i talk about it here already yeah we
probably already talked about that
what is the first thing you do in the
morning i don't want to talk to you
about this this site sucks do you
recycle
do you recycle all right let's talk
about it okay yeah yeah i think are you
recycling i think this is a great
opportunity for us to talk about things
that we don't really understand
which is my favorite stuff to talk about
because i have i have feelings about
this because
we just received something
on our trash can
yep i did you receive it as well
yeah absolutely you get a bucket on top
you got a freaking bucket on top of your
trash can yeah they're doing this in los
angeles but i think this is a good thing
this is a good thing dude why are you
angry so there's i don't know how to use
it yet i think it's a scam so
it must be an la county thing um
i had a ring at the doorbell i go up to
the door and i open it and
you had a doorbell and down there
like
what like in the middle like not right
at the like even further out than where
they would normally drop a package you
know package droppers are pretty good
about like putting it behind the flower
pots and stuff like that getting it
close so it won't get stolen yeah this
this bucket and i would say
it was kind of squarish
probably um you know 10 inches square
14 inches tall 14 inches tall it's a
pail it's got a it i think it has a
handle and it has a lid it does
squares it has like
um stickers around it did you read the
instructions not yet oh i did me and
jesse had a whole conversation i can't i
keep meaning to but i was like i'm not
i'm not ready for this burden well i'm
about to blow your mind so it's a
compost
bucket
where
the
i wouldn't call it a compost bucket that
would be an overstatement the co it's a
plastic bucket i would call it a bucket
made of plastic
that is for food waste and you're
supposed to put your food waste in it
because
as we know the pigs need to eat it
but uh because if you start putting a
bunch of food waste in the landfill it
creates uh methane it's not good for the
environment so whereas if you did
something if you did the right thing
with food waste you can turn it into
soil there's actually uh
products
i know of at least one product out there
that like you can you can get like a
highfalutin machine
that will that will
uh turn it was a sponsor of ours
yeah i don't know if it's out yet
but yeah i'm going to give you i'm going
to give you the instructions and give
you a couple of some some additional
information yeah because i was talking
to lando about it's like what do we do
with this bucket because my chief
question was do do they pick it up every
week and dump it out i'm going to tell
you and is this a different truck let me
tell you like the taxes going into this
i mean this is this is i think this
represents progress i think this is a
good thing so i'm i'm i'm on i'm i feel
positive about it i feel good about it i
don't know how to feel about it and i'm
going to tell you in a second how i
don't know how to feel about it um
but
you're right that it has to do with
methane or methane if you're british
i am not um
and it has to do with the fact that
methane is a gotta make it all about
them is a greenhouse gas that uh while
there's not nearly as much methane
released on a daily basis
uh it is much more of a greenhouse gas
like the whatever the the magnitude
per like
metric ton of methane like the the the
impact in terms of greenhouse gas is
much higher so it takes a little bit of
methane to make a lot of bad stuff
happen
okay
uh compared to compared to co2 so
because i was i was also thinking like
why is this the thing that they're
talking about and again
i believe i i am an environmentalist and
i believe in the
i believe in the science
behind
uh you know global warming climate
change and i think we got to start you
know we should have a long time ago i
started doing things so i believe in
this in theory i'll tell you why i'm
questioning it in a little bit but
what you do
is you put your food waste and it has a
list of acceptable food waste
liquids are not included in the food
waste like you can't put liquid in there
and you can't pour like your milk in
there and you can't um
put like your grease in there so we're
talking right food actual
organic food waste banana peels
eggshells uh are the two things lando
told me i don't know about meat and
bones
but i doubt i don't know doubt you can
put that in there it's all on the thing
but what you do is you take a plastic
bag and it said you can use any plastic
bag including the ones that you get from
the grocery store okay
and you put you line the bag with a you
line the bucket with a plastic bag
then you take that you tie it up and you
throw that whole plastic bag into your
green
bin
what your yard waste bin yard waste bin
and so jesse and i were talking about we
have we have three bins just so you know
we got a black bin that's the naughty
trash we've got the blue bin which is
the recyclables
turns out there's a lot of you can't put
in there that you thought you could and
then now there's this little bucket that
is a is a
a temporary container for a bag that
holds food waste that goes into your
green
yard waste bag yeah so like leaves and
if you limbs you can cut a bush up on
your uh property and you put those limbs
in there yeah
it goes in there with those so this
leads to this this leads to a question
what
which jessie asked
she's like
well that's a really messy job for
somebody
so somebody is sitting somewhere with a
plastic bag which is
plastic bad
we know plastic is bad right
now i will
every couple of trips to the grocery
store ask for plastic bags because i use
those plastic bags for things at
home
you know like if i'm traveling which i
have a tendency to do
i take my kit we call it like toiletries
bag
my dad called it a kit so that's what i
ended up calling it okay and i put that
because it has some liquids in there i
put that inside of a plastic bag and
second layer of safety because of what
happened to
uh your clothes yeah when we were
visiting chicago like 15 years ago
because i had a very very greasy pomade
murray's pomade and it and we decided to
combine suitcases like somehow
it got put in my suitcase
yeah and it exploded well
all over the place let me just say that
the idea to pack one suitcase was
probably mr frugal's idea just that was
not my idea but the idea to bring the
murray's pomade and the idea to put the
murray's pomade in my hair it's not
necessarily made from my type of hair
but i wore it for many years
it like melted and
spilled out because it's not a screw top
and it leaked onto how many of your
shirts like
everything a lot a lot of things i was
wearing man everything i brought uh i'm
sorry about that
if i haven't apologized before
um
but that probably didn't but that is why
i think i did that is why and i might
accept your apology one day i put things
in a plastic bag and i do other things
with plastic bags but so somebody is
sitting at the center where the yard
waste comes and every day up until
before this thing
they just been like okay yeah leaves and
stuff and everyone's you know somebody's
doing some dumb [ __ ]
every once in a while the guys who are
collecting the yard waste are like oh
somebody put one of them poop bags in
here from the oh somebody on a walk
you know okay that's the thing that's
that's helping me make sense of this
because they're already doing the work
because first of all they take the green
bin and just like the blue and the black
ones a
a specified truck comes by picks it up
and dumps it all into the truck
so it's not like someone walks up to and
takes starts picking at it right there
in front of your house it's just like
every other truck and when it gets to
the facility
yes somebody is already picking through
the yard waste stuff
to get out the stuff that shouldn't have
been in there
so now
they're going to be a lot busier they're
getting these bags and then what are
they doing with these bags and then
who's the next person who gets the bags
and they get bags that are just full of
rotten food
yeah and then then now we've got oh this
which leads me into the next thing which
is the reason that i think this might be
a scam it's not a scam is what do you do
with those dirty plastic bags they got
stuff all in them because what i've been
told you can't recycle you can't recycle
dirty plastic and now we're just putting
a bunch of dirty plastic
into the green bin
tell me what tell me what i'm missing we
need to take a tour
because i was also told
that they're not actually recycling
stuff yeah they just ship it to china
and then china buries it they're like oh
yeah this makes you feel good no again
we don't know i am saying i i
i want them to recycle i think they
should be recycling
i'm going to choose to recycle i'm going
to choose to follow the system
but i have my doubts that the system is
actually doing the thing that the system
promised to do well it's it's
experimental so what do you like okay
i've got to look this up what do you do
peanut butter if you get done with a
peanut butter do you
you lick the inside of it out do you do
you do you put your peanut butter in the
dishwasher thereby using energy to get
the remnants of peanut butter out and
then yeah i've washed it out um you wash
out the inside of a peanut butter before
you put it in the recycling a few times
and that was what hot water
hot water and soap because lando did a
whole presentation about
this stuff he's the one who knows about
starting to recycle cool stuff yeah then
you start feeling guilty about
everything well he came home and was
like the enforcer well you got to have
one in every household yeah he got on me
about the peanut butter
you can't recycle this unless it's
totally clean dad so i started cleaning
it so and then i was like you know what
after doing that twice i was like now
i'm just throwing it in the regular
trash because
because
i recycle we recycle a lot bad person
it's just a lot of recycling is up in
the trash anyway is what i what i
believed
starting january first instead of
throwing that container of fuzzy
strawberries into the trash this is the
la times a new law will require
californians to recycle their food
scraps and other leftovers
city bill 1383 mandates that you toss
organic material into bins you use for
other green waste such as garden
trimmings long-term sleeves
this is part of a larger effort to
reduce short-lived climate pollutants
including methane
methane
and redirect organic waste from
landfills back to the soil as compost or
mulch if you're unsure about how to get
started here's some tips food that can
be recycled coffee grounds coffee
filters and non-nylon tea bags
fruit and vegetable scraps even the
moldy parts egg shells
use slash dirty paper
food containers
paper food containers
like it like if you get like in and out
uh animal fries like that's a paper
container that's greasy
juice pulp
paper towels and tissues
you can put paper towels and tissues and
paper plates
what food that can be recycled includes
paper plates well i've been eating my
paper plates for years so that that
tracks some cities ex settings accept
more food items for example santa monica
also accepts meat seafood scraps and
dairy products
check with your local
municipality does it say what happens to
it um
i'm scrolling
what happens to it no
i am right about this place it doesn't
say what happens to it
brian did you see that
you do use the plastic bag right because
that's
in my mind we had that conversation and
jesse was like yes you can use it
because it said grocery bag
yeah that's just that just that part
it doesn't make sense to me because why
can't i just take
the raw stuff and just throw it in there
with the bushes i guess because they
don't want the bushes to be mixed up
what do they do with the bushes they're
doing a different thing the grass
and you if you're concerned about odors
you can layer the food with sawdust or
line it with paper towels is that really
going to do it you can also put the
container in the fridge or freezer
so you that's a
so that's why the bucket is so small so
you can put it in your freezer
does it say anything on there this
method is putting the scraps in a brown
paper bag and putting it in your freezer
and then figure out where you want that
to go after like the farmer's market
what
see we should be composting stuff in our
backyard
you know but we're not doing that all
right so that's la that doesn't say
wasn't the same thing about the bags
what should i google what happens
what happens next
just google what happens next we all
need to know
california compost law everything you
need to know
so all right this should include
everything we need to know we need to
know what happens next where will all
the compost go
click
i just want to make sure that i haven't
complicated things for the for the
compost people all organic waste would
be converted to soil like compost and
used for agriculture let's explore some
other options for managing your food
waste now this doesn't have everything
you need to know yeah that's definitely
not everything i need to know you know
what this is this is actually an ad for
loamy which is the freaking
i got tricked i got tricked into
clicking on the loamy website which and
it's and then the number one thing you
can do use an electric composter and
then up here it says get loamy which uh
is a sponsor on gmm but it ain't a
sponsor here so we're gonna move on but
that is something you can do use an
electric composter
um i yeah i don't know what happens to
it pizza boxes cannot be recycled
but can they now go in this compost they
won't fit they're too big for the bucket
but is cardboard a paper food container
you can put the pizza boxes in the blue
bin oh yeah you can you can but not if
there's still pizza as long
if you're getting good pizza it's got
cheese on it man i mean the cheese has
been sticking to things
well fox 11 says banana peels chicken
bones and leftover veggies won't have a
place in california trash cans under the
new
under the nation's largest mandatory
residential food waste recycling program
um
yeah i want to know what they do with it
they're just telling us what to do with
it and all of this i think they do what
you said they do with it they're going
to take it and they're like they're
going to go through it and they're going
to make it into soil we've got all this
organic material that now is going to be
used in agriculture and versus just
riding in a landfill somewhere and
giving off methane
um
i remember one time do you remember we
were in asheville north carolina
uh
you may have been for burying me
naturally on commercial kings
we met a guy and his name was like
whistle or something like that you know
it's like one of those guys that sort of
just like lives on the street of
asheville an old guy sort of like hippie
i don't think it was whistle but it's
like it had a name like that
he
uh
said
how much trash
how much trash do you make
remember he asked that question how much
trash do you make
and i was like i don't know a lot and he
was like and he held up a bag
and it was
the same size as the pail that you've
already described yeah 10 by 10 probably
14 inches tall
he's like this is all the trash i
generate in a year
and he just holds it for a year so he
was about to throw it away wow he caught
him at a perfect time
um it's been one year so he was making a
point but i will say
i think about this often okay so this is
what this is the part of this that
bothers me and i think the reason that
this conversation kind of like
it makes me feel uncomfortable
because
i mean there have been times
a few times actually
where
we might you know we have people over
for parties or whatever game night or
and you feed people and you all of a
sudden you generated more trash than you
typically would as a family in those
weeks yeah sometimes
we get we we can barely one week seven
days of four people living in america
plus their friends living
living it up at their house a little bit
yep
fills up the entire trash can oh yeah
and then the recycling sometimes is
filled up and sometimes i'll be like
okay we're gonna have to just
put this in a bag and hope they also
take it because it won't fit or we'll
put it in a bag and leave it next to the
trash can
or leave it up there and then they'll
take it and then we'll put it it will
you know we'll overflow into the next
week
right my point is
it's clear if you just do the math right
this is totally unsustainable so much
trash that
just a little family of four
is making that much trash in a week when
whistle is over there
in asheville making this little bag and
then of course if you start if you
compare what we're the waste that we're
generating to
a developing country
it's gonna be a whole lot less per
capita like if everyone was living the
way that we were living it would just be
absolute mayhem but it kind of is mayhem
have you been to a landfill
yeah
i i did it
it stinks
well should we just dig a hole yeah we
just dig a hole we make up digging a
hole and throwing stuff in it and i'm
me and my family
we're adding
trash that weighs more than all of us
put together every single week
i mean i i'm every i've i've i i can't
defend myself
it's like this how do you do that what
do you say i mean i'm filling up my
recycle bin every week i'm i'm putting
on my boots and i'm getting i'm climbing
up in it and jumping up and down to get
as much into the recycling as possible
like i couldn't recycle more unless i
got a second bin which i guess i could
do and but now i'm gonna i'm gonna do
this food waste thing
and by the way
um this is still the fox site
uh
they're talking about somebody in davis
davis
california already has a mandatory food
recycle program and joy a mother of
three
um
puts all of her cooking scraps into a
metal bin labeled compost on her
countertop
when preparing dinner she empties excess
food from the cutting board into the bin
etc after a few days she dumps the
contents into her green waste bin
outside that is picked up and sent to a
county facility unpleasant countertop
bin smells haven't been a problem
all you're changing is where you're
throwing things away it's just another
bent it's really easy and it's amazing
how much less trash you have
i mean the thing about throwing away
trash is that when you get the when you
get that food stuff in there but that
stuff starts to ooze out and you might
you get animals showing up
yeah i mean i've had my trash can
knocked over
decimated five times since i moved to
where i'm at raccoons buy something i
think it might be a team of raccoons
um in a trench coat because i don't know
how they get the damn trash can over but
it seems like they're not putting it in
a bag in davis at least she's dumped
yeah yeah i gotta look i gotta re-read
contents directly into the green waste
bin
along with all of the other
stuff so the plastic bag thing
is it feels like it might be wrong that
may be your your misunderstanding well
you know i'm going to say my wife was
the one reading it so i'm going to blame
her i'm going to read it tonight
perpetuate we'll do another we're going
to do another question after after we
talk a little bit about good mythical
evening
good mythical evening is september 1st
it is an r rated
live event watch it as it happens as we
go
go full r
exclusively on moment house yeah it is
i'm telling you you should you should be
there for it i have promised i'm gonna
be there that um
i think we all know we've we've talked
about the fact that
uh link took us all a little off guard
last year with getting a little too
intoxicated and uh
i was like do i need to
hold down the fort and i made the
decision to hold down the four and
stevie was very thankful and
let me know that but i've let stevie
know that she is the only person who
would be holding down the fort
uh this year
so
you know i i think
i i think the question is gonna be
uh
are you going to try to outdo yourself
because you i mean
there could be a there could be a line
that you don't need to cross and it's
going to try to outdo yourself or am i
going to just meet you at the place that
you were
are you going to try to
separate yourself
it could get a little tricky if that's
your mentality especially if you got
those glasses on
wouldn't you like to know but there's
only one way to find out and that's to
watch good mythical evening when it
happens go mythicalevening.com you got
to buy a ticket good mythically.com
talked enough about recycling
um
and stuff
composting
we've talked too much about it i believe
in it i'm just gonna say i just it it
stresses me out man we're blazing the
trail there's still plenty of places on
earth in
in in america and many counties
that they don't recycle well there's no
resources
if you see one of those videos where
it's a it's a literal river of plastic
trash
that's probably not the u.s i'm just
going to say it's probably not the u.s
u.s has got a lot of problems and the us
is generating a lot of this a lot of
these problems but we don't have just
rivers of plastic
crap that hasn't happened yet
but anyway we just got to stop making
that stuff i think that's the thing
that's frustrating is that
the way that we talk about this is we
talk about personal responsibility and
we want every individual to do what they
do their part which i believe in
but when you are faced with a system
where every single time you go to the
grocery store
95 of the things that you're going to
buy are going to come
in something that then creates trash
every time you go out to eat you're
going to create trash like there's like
larger sys systemic issues that you
can't just wait for every individual to
make the right decisions like we have to
have systemic change so that we all
don't you can't just rely on people to
make all kinds of good decisions because
people are going to do what the easy
thing is man people ain't going to wash
their freaking peanut butter out it's a
yeah unless your kid does a project and
they do it twice it's a both and i'm
willing to accept increasing
responsibility in education
as long as it happens on other levels
conversation starters.com not a sponsor
yet
hit it
what's the longest you've gone without
sleep
what is it okay all right
okay conversation starters.com oh
man the ai heard us talking about it was
like okay try this one on precise boys i
mean
i definitely
am on record saying that i
i never elected to pull an all-nighter
in college which is the first place i
think that you're going to be apt
to stay up all night
except for that one time that we went
snowboarding in the mountains
and it's a good place to snowboard and
we yeah it is we went so we go to the
plane you know we had to drive a number
of hours you start skiing at like
1am the night ski at hawk's nest same
place seems this is this was the
scenario under which i broke my pelvis
and and suffered the concussion but i
remember
at a at a preceding time we did it you
start skiing at one you skip from like
one to f
maybe like one to four does that sound
right to you night skiing night skiing
they got the lights on
i don't believe you're right about that
you think it's done by one i
my best guess it might be done because
first of all during the winter
sunset is probably 5 30 or 6.
yeah so i think it's probably six to
midnight night skiing yeah and then i
think i think you might could go to one
and they got to make snow at some point
and then we had to drive back
and maybe stopping at the waffle house
and all that stuff by the time i got
back i i went
i did not sleep i went straight to class
and i just remember
being in my
medieval history class
and i could not stay awake and i was
taking notes and i literally
was able to look back at my notes and
see
the moment that i fell asleep because
it's a movie which just became a squishy
line it's just like a
yeah it it the line just kind of
squiggled down
off the page
and that's how i want to die i was
fighting i was fighting it so hard you
know you just cannot stay awake any
longer
that was so i remember that being an
all-nighter
i don't recall that
the i mean the most recent
all-nighter was when we shot hazel
and we were fighting against the sun
coming up that's right
so this is in case you didn't know this
is the uh tick tock
first
uh
we released it on tick tock and then we
put it on the rhett link youtube channel
but basically our horror you know
spending a night in the creative house
kind of thing
um nobody watched it
but if you were there for when it
happened you were awesome you were
thrilled by it the um which is great
we obviously we stayed up all day
because that's typically what we do
because i'm i'm not a vampire
and i also don't take naps but then
the
night shoot rolled around and
you know ben had the shot list planned
as soon as it gets dark we start because
we got to shoot in the dark we had
talked about potentially like doing
blackout
of the windows but
we were trying to avoid that because it
takes a bunch of time yeah so it was we
had one night in the woods which did not
take all night and then the next night
i believe it's when we went back to the
creative house and we were shooting all
night in the house and that's the one
that went all the way till the sun came
up
yes we actually kind of going on less
sleep i just remember
the sun coming up and that was when we
were packing everything up and putting
it back in the trucks
and
being very tired but not being sleepy
like my body was like okay well we
missed that opportunity
and then i was like i'm going to go home
i don't know what's that opportunity
what to say to sleep
but now circadian rhythm is in play and
your body's like okay well now
it's okay i guess another day is here
and i have such a difficult time
sleeping during the day i know i had to
i don't remember but i had to have slept
you didn't sleep during the day no no i
went home and slept for
i think probably two hours
and then woke up and was like i guess
i'll just you know i'll never make up
for this
i don't think i've ever done more than
that what what i've never done because
obviously we did the same thing with uh
all night long all night long when we
sing
lionel richie's all night long
literally for 11 hours all night long
it's on youtube check it out and uh
check it out brian you didn't know about
that
that was from sundown to sunrise and
then again same thing like go home that
was easy because we were constantly
um
[Music]
engaged in occupied
and there were certain scenes with the
hazel thing especially towards the the
morning
like they were shooting something with
you and then i had this down time and
once you sit down and you get still that
gets difficult we had one all-nighter
for buddy system two
um
well buddy system also it was uh season
one
so yeah we've had a few all-nighters but
i'm i'm neither one of us have ever been
the type of person to say let's just
stay up all night
and i can do that you know there's
people who can do that
okay i mean i get when i get really
tired
i start to feel like nauseous
it's like my body just starts shutting
down
well
i'm about to i'm about to scare you a
little bit
you're about to tell me it's actually a
good thing you should be doing it on a
monthly basis
no no no
well i read that book while we sleep
which then i found out that
at least some of the research that the
guy had quoted in it was not right and
so i don't know what part that was i
didn't follow up okay but but he one of
the things he talks about is you
basically don't make up for it like you
can't
you don't make up for lost sleep like
whatever the effects of missing sleep
have
it's you get those effects and they're
short-term and then of course
compounding there's long-term effects
and like one of the things he talks
about is people who are chronically uh
under-sleeping
like you hear people like steve harvey
he's one of them who will say like
i sleep four hours a day
yeah leno says the same thing
and there's this like pride of like you
only sleep four hours and this guy's
point was that
yes there is a range of what people
require but really nobody can get away
with that little sleep
they're suffering they're suffering
consequences that are long-term health
consequences so when steve harvey's
mustache just falls off one day
it's probably because he's only getting
four hours of sleep
that's how it happens huh it starts with
a mustache
now there's been a couple of times you
know i told you earlier in the year when
i started struggling a little bit with
insomnia and then i think i figured out
that it had to do with the intermittent
fasting thing i was doing and that's
kind of a common side effect but it
didn't go away for me
but because i'm a
hypochondriac or i have
whatever health anxiety whatever the
proper term is today okay
there was a point in which
i was waking up and not being able to go
by to sleep and i thought that i might
have
a
fatal familial familial insomnia what
fatal familial
it's a rare genetic degenerative you
can't sleep and it kills a family member
it is well that can happen it is
characterized by an inability to sleep
insomnia that may be initially mild
but progressively worsens leading to
significant physical and mental
deterioration
affected individuals may also develop
dysfunction of the on
autonomic nervous system the part of the
nervous system that controls involuntary
automatic body processes
well yeah but basically why do you think
you have it i don't have it you just got
scared
i wasn't sleeping i mean it is a form of
torture i would hate i i hate it for the
people who can't sleep like that's it's
just you're not it is literally a form
of but you're not listening to me i'm
listening to you i'm not talking about
somebody who can't sleep i'm talking
about a disease
in which you slowly lose the ability to
sleep and invariably die gosh you're not
listening to what i'm saying bro i'm not
talking about insomnia i'm talking about
chronic insomnia that they do not have a
cure for and it happens to some people
and they just freaking die so you say
awake to death
yes
well i heard you i eventually
man that is a nightmare and i've you
know
i i i hate to make i'm not making light
of it because i thought i had it but
somebody does somebody does have it they
don't know what to do about it they
can't they can't do anything about it
there's no treatment for it
i mean there's got to be like some like
high-powered something to knock you out
i don't i don't think so i think that
you your
whatever is in your brain that allows
you to sleep eventually just goes away
but what's how long can you go without
sleep before you die
that's another question yeah i'm not
getting that one from
conversationstarters.com i got that one
from my brain how long how long
can you stay awake without dying because
you can go
a few days without water
right
yeah you can go
if you're not sleeping without food you
need to stay hydrated
you need to eat
yes the longest recorded time without
sleep is approximately
264 hours or just over 11 consecutive
days
what
now that person just
probably fell asleep
i don't know if they died
um
you know and there's like you know
you
you'll you'll you'll have like minor
body altering drugs that will keep you
keep you awake in order to get stuff
done beyond caffeine stuff that stuff i
don't even want to know about
i mean i love sleeping there's times
when i get in the bed and i'm just like
i'll just i'll just be so happy that i'm
in my bed i'll just squeal
yeah
you know just like wiggle up in there
and just get snuggly
but but now that these dogs like we got
jasper and jade in the bed and they're
freaking
they'll they move around and you know we
got these aura rings that talk that they
track all of our movement and give me a
sleep score every morning and it's very
helpful information
and
i
i hate to say it but it's made me think
that like the dogs don't need to stay in
the bed
you know because
whenever they move around it makes me
move my hand that has my ring on it and
then my sleep score lowers what i don't
know if i'm actually making sure where
did they sleep in relation to you and
christie and is it consistent
it's
uh j jade sleeps
on my right side
in between my arm and my hip
facing her nose faces down and her butt
faces my my armpit so i kind of like
have my arm over her because you sleep
on your back because you got a special
pillow yeah i sleep on my back because
it's the superior way to sleep and then
and so i've trained myself to do it with
my uh very uncomfortable
brick
cylinder pillow and then
jasper will he'll burrow down to the
bottom and then
in the middle of the night we'll just
hear him like whimpering down there he
doesn't know how to get out but no he's
not suffocating he just i mean
dachshunds are like burrowing dogs they
love to burrow down but then he wants to
get out and then i'll have to like wake
up enough to like lift the covers and
then he sees the exit jade never had
this problem when she was younger
jasper's probably dumber and then ah
jess i think jess was smarter he's just
dumb in this area dumb in this area and
then he will climb up and he will he
will go and he will lay
above christy's head
which can't be good for her sleep but
like he's like it's
i mean if she was sitting up and he was
still in the same place it would be like
she was wearing jasper like a hat this
happens every every night every other
night he usually gets up there and
perches as a hat on her head um
yeah so that kind of is disturbing our
quality of sleep you know it's more of a
jasper thing than a jade thing but then
every four nights
jade will
get up out of the bed
and
she's thirsty
oh yeah she's a neil she wants some she
wants some water
and
so i got a little mug of water i put in
the bathroom but she but she won't walk
in the bathroom get it and just jump
back in bed she'll get out of the bed
and she'll shake her head and like
flop her ears to wake me up so that i
will escort her to the bathroom this is
this is obviously dysfunctional why
don't you put the water bowl next to the
bed
i don't know
i don't know i mean it feels like that
problem can be solved that's a good idea
right
like why do why does the water bowl have
to be in the bathroom just put a little
water bowl next to the nightstand on the
side that she comes off of
and and it could be a dog bowl instead
of a human
cup that i used to use uh when i brush
my teeth
yeah yeah i'm not really thinking it's
just a dog bowl and then she can also
probably get a little swig right before
she goes to bed you know how you go
months
without
thinking you have a problem and you just
don't stop and think strategically about
it thank you for bringing me out of my
stupor i mean it's kind of like parents
who sleep with their their their their
baby in the bed and then next thing you
know their baby's six years old and
still in the bed alicia silverstone you
know it's like i mean you got a person
at a certain point who's in charge here
her kid's 11. now
yeah you get them why don't you say
something you've got 11 year old in the
middle why don't you dig yourself a
little hole let's talk about alicia
silverstone and her child who's 11
sleeping in the bed with her and dig
yourself a little hole i mean i just i
just feel like you've got
i'm guilty of it
you're you
no well i've never done that i'm guilty
of it with the dog with the with the cup
thing so i'm not above reproach here but
there's a certain point when you have to
come to your senses and say
who's in charge here
who's the who's the parent and who's the
puppy
who's the
who's the talk about children who's
clueless not puppies and who's an 11
year old
human
yeah it's like i thought her at a
certain point they got to be in their
own bed
okay
tell that to all the parts of the world
in which they there's a family bed that
they all sleep in oh god rep why
why are you doing this to me
because i'm just
i'm showing you
uh because i think the same way as you
when i heard about alicia silverstone's
child sleeping in the bed with her at 11
i was like well that kid's gonna have x
y and z
is never gonna be able to let go of the
mom i didn't say any of that i just said
it's like at a certain point you need to
sleep but i'm just as guilty of it with
a dog
no two dogs but it was interesting
and i don't think she made this she
didn't care she doesn't care she
obviously doesn't care she's been
there's been a number of things that
alicia silverstone has done
in relationship to her i think the first
thing was like she like did them she was
the mama bird feeder of the child like
chewing the food and yeah giving the
food i think
don't quote me on that but i think that
was the first sort of controversial
thing an unconventional thing and then
it was the 11 year old it was the most
recent thing of course if she would have
been
in buddy system as was discussed for a
brief moment oh yeah we wouldn't be
having this conversation now because she
would be fine and we would totally
understand i'm definitely we'd be on her
side well she didn't really defend
herself because she doesn't care to care
to
but in the article i was reading about
it
somebody was talking about the fact that
yeah
there's really no evidence that this is
going to cause any particular problems
with the child
the only thing you really want to avoid
is you definitely don't want your just
having your own life i mean like sleep
means so much to me that it's just like
the kid will be okay in another room
i mean there's exceptions to every rule
but like in general
i'm talking about the kid for a second
so yesterday i'm not gonna let my kids
sleep with me in my bed
yeah because i'm because i want to be in
my own bed and i want to sleep
but if you if you're thinking about it
from their perspective
what you really don't want to do is you
don't want to have like a newborn baby
in the bed because that's where you roll
over and you kill the baby i mean that
happens right some people don't horrible
don't know what's going on and stuff
yeah uh
but yeah to me it's just like it's more
of a convenience thing but the point
that these like psychologists were
making is that no it's actually not it
doesn't necessarily mean that this kid
is going to have like attachment issues
we don't know that but we don't have
reason to think so and also this is the
way that many
humans have slept together
for many many years there was a family
still in many places in the world
there's like
a family bed there's a place there's a
room that everybody sleeps in it's like
a den you know of everybody
sleeping together
so and i guess if you want to if you're
mom and dad or
mom and mom and dad and dad and you want
to have a little uh hanky-panky
yeah what about the hanky pants i think
you
you go to a different place go to the
kids room
they don't have a room
you go to the kitchen i guess
while everybody's sleeping you go to the
living room
like that like that couple that was
having sex in the living room
we were talking about last time oh yeah
a couple times ago whenever that was
let me just back to sleeping
for a science fair project in 1965
randy gardner
set the world record by going 206
hours
roughly 11 days without sleep now first
of all how
i don't know who this ra i mean it
wasn't more than the high school i mean
randy gardner
science fair do you do people do science
in the 60s were there like adults doing
science fair projects because i don't
know enough about this
but the 60s seems like the last decade
in which
like a 8th grader could be making this
decision and everybody's like well randy
hear about randy yeah the gardener boy
he's been up for nine days and you know
nobody's worried about whether he's
gonna die they're just they're getting
ready to do a parade
you know in the 60s it was like the last
decade that you could really let randy
go 11 days without sleeping is he gonna
die we don't know if he's gonna die but
you know what he's not gonna die he's
doing this for the town
he's doing it for the blue ribbon he's
putting the school on the map
randy gardner this resulted in
significant this is rise science.com
also not a sponsor
what happened but the what happened to
randy i would just say the web design on
rise science is better than
conversation starters yeah my two cents
uh
this resulted in significant declines in
his concentration motivation perception
in higher level mental processes
all part of the experiment a 2017 npr
interview with gardner yes revealed
signs of nausea
on the third morning that's a weird way
to put that you mean this many years
later
revealed signs of
you mean randy told you that he was sick
on the third day it's just a weird way
to write it on the third day
randy gardner got a little nauseous but
i knew i needed to win
most worryingly he complained of memory
loss which he felt like
an early alzheimer's thing brought on by
lack of sleep
an early alzheimer's thing
well he you know oh he's not a scientist
he's a kid who did a science project
in other words the human body isn't made
to withstand sleep deprivation to any
degree
i did a science project
uh
where i was
you know talk about the environmental
thing from the top of this conversation
where um we buried toilet tissue
different types of toilet paper when we
saw the rate that it would bio degrade
um
over the course of like a couple of
months
like none of them
biodegraded at all
it was kind of a it was kind of a short
so what did
don't bury your toilet paper
hold on randy is still alive of course
he is in san diego
how's he doing now how's his nausea he's
an american from san diego california
okay so that's the record for the
longest amount of time a human has gone
without sleep
in december
16 i don't think guinness allows this
record they don't certify it anymore
because it it it does harm you know so i
don't i don't think they certify this
type of record 17 year old gardener
stayed awake for 11 days in 25 minutes
breaking the previous record of 260
hours by tom rounds i don't don't go i
don't want to hear about tom no he's a
loser
oh tom he's clicking on tom
wikipedia is trying to get me to donate
i'll do that on my own time okay
oh tom rounds
was
means he's dead he died in 2014 was an
american radio broadcasting executive
founder and chief executive
officer of radio express in burbank
california okay these people who stand
up for hey man we might be next on the
list these people who aren't sleeping
are in california southern california
both of them tom rounds and randy
gardner what about rep mclaughlin and
lake neal
i i think it would be a funny video for
us to see how long we could stay up
because but it only gets like you only
need to show the last hour you know
because like you know that dozing off
thing that you just do you just like you
that would be funny yeah
we i think we could do something with
that i mean
how long do you think you could stay up
longer than you
definitely
but like you can't like
no caffeine
you can you can't have any substances
like to to to aid in your
staying awake it feels it feels right it
could be boring
i mean this is what yeah it's edited
this is what mr rounds did tom while in
hawaii
he hoping to gain publicity for his new
position as a disc jockey
set the
world record for sleeplessness the
period of 260 hours awake was attained
while rounds was sitting in a department
store window
this is awesome publicity snot now i am
remembering back in the
burgeoning days of live streaming
shay carl and charles trippy ever the
innovators of the time
probably 2008 maybe 2007. they did a
24 7 broadcast of them staying awake
24 hours
no as long as they could go to see who
could go the longest between the two of
them
remember that because i watched some of
it okay i'm gonna look that up i don't
know who went who went long charles
trippy
shea carl we were down there in
lillington not
sleeping
it looks like there aren't
many good matches for your sh i
definitely remember this happening
it was like a justin tv
uh i mean twitch didn't exist
you know ustream type thing
i can't i can't find how long they went
but that's sad that it's not anywhere on
the internet randy did eventually
recover
um
and according to news reports gardner's
record has been broken a number of times
uh
but there's no official certification of
it
i you know i
i take it back i don't want to have
anything to do with this um sleep is way
too precious for me you know it's just
it's
it's like time travel that's what i
always say
one minute you're in one day next minute
you're in the next day
that means you slept well though
if it feels like it if it feels like
football
you know anesthesia
the australian national sleep research
project which is my favorite australian
national sleep research project
okay um
states the record for sleep deprivation
is 18 days 21 hours and 40 minutes so
that's another seven days wow almost
another nine days that is torture i mean
that is torture
it's not going to happen to me
uh but i'm just like i'm hoping it
doesn't happen to me i i think i want to
lose my mustache um
i think that
the thing that i've been
focusing on lately and i do think that
it has a lot to do with us getting these
rings
and also before that like when i would
wear that the reason i was wearing the
apple watch and this and then it was
kind of like oh i got two smart things
just oh you're kind of still doing it
yeah i'm doing too smart thanks um but i
can only do one smart thing at a time
and uh
but it makes you more conscious of it
and i have to i'm the
i'm the advocate for sleep in my home
this is where i think that i have a
little bit more of some challenges built
in because my impression is that chris
you'll fall asleep before you sometimes
yeah i mean she's still in summer mode
she's staying up a little later now what
does she do in the summer she has a mint
julep at night what happens what do you
mean
she just stays up later uh for the
summer for the summer because of the
light
because of the light uh
i think coming back from vacation
and the kid's still out of school she's
still like
kind of with the kids in terms of
staying up later
but i'm not i'm back i'm back working it
my wife never goes to sleep before me
and i have to have these little like
sessions where i'm i'm like hey
you know
i can we can we try to go to bed before
midnight and she's like you can you can
go to bed whenever you want so i'm like
yeah but i'm a light sleeper and
i don't i can try to go to sleep before
you do but like you getting in the bed
is going to wake me up like can we go to
bed i'm going to go to bed earlier and
you know i'm making slow progress but
the other thing i was thinking about the
other day was
you know one of the
i follow a few different
sort of like doctor accounts like doctor
influencers like rhonda patrick and
andrew huberman okay um who i think they
both have their own podcast but
who doesn't
they have podcasts where there's like
legit information that is given not just
two guys with a laptop
and um
who are these two guys they sound cool
but the one thing that she was saying
the other day was
she does a thing on her instagram where
she will be like here's the latest study
about this thing and i'm gonna like
summarize it and tell you what you need
to know about this
okay and it was a study of
six to 12 year olds
and how basically six to 12 year olds
need to get a minimum of nine hours of
sleep preferably nine to 12 hours wow
and if they don't get at least nine
hours of sleep this study shows
that
they end up with
memory
issues attention deficit issues
impulsive impulse control issues
basically the things that you kind of
think about when you think about teens
but some of these things may be
diagnosable as well
um
and i was just thinking two things
number one whoa it's too late it's too
late for my kids
you know because
like
it's very difficult to get shepard to
have a sleep schedule he he won't go to
bed on his own
you eventually like some time during the
pandemic you know he eventually just
kind of gave up on it
we'd fi sometimes we'd go down the
middle of night we'd find him like on
the computer playing video games at like
3 a.m and like we would discipline him
we would change you do all the things to
try to stop it but he hasn't gotten
consistent sleep now that he's like a
teenager
at least during the summer he's sleeping
late so maybe he ends up getting i don't
know but the thing i was thinking in
addition to well it was too late for me
and my kids was
we live in a really interesting time
in which we've got all this information
we we we have we know
so many things
there's so much there's so much so many
studies have been done still so much
that we don't know a lot more than we
don't know that we do know but
like if i was i feel like it would be
different it's different to be
like if we were the typical la 44 year
olds who were like had a newborn
just think about at this stage in in
this stage in my life oh my gosh with
this much more internet having happened
in my brain
and this much more access to
oh information you're talking about
being a better parent
i'm just talk i don't i'm i'm what i'm
saying is i'm kind of glad
i'm kind of glad i'm almost done yeah
because
i didn't know about
stuff i didn't i didn't know like well
they should be doing this or they
shouldn't be i mean there's things that
we knew we shouldn't you know we should
have been giving our kids cigarettes
like we were right right i mean that was
a mistake and i probably could have
known that
um no but i'm talking about and then the
stuff the lit end is on the outside yeah
yeah yeah yeah
figure that out
i don't know
it's a blessing and a curse because what
is what's done is done in one sense hey
what's done is done man uh but if i was
a if i was like have i had a newborn
right now oh gosh
like with
all the stuff they try to sell the world
is so different too and like there's
there's this there's covid and there's
you know these things you gotta well my
god that's a monkey box
you know and and then your kids can't be
on screens and they're gonna get nine to
twelve hours of sleep and you got to be
taking these vitamins when you're
pregnant
it's like
and now they got to put their like food
waste in a different bucket yeah our
kids our kids just threw the food waste
out the car window
you know i'm saying he's going down the
highway just throwing banana peels on
the roadside
now they got to put it in a bin
i don't know i think i'm glad my kids
are one's about to go off to college
we'll talk about that in an upcoming
episode that's right
uh i don't know exactly when we're
talking about that but
after it happens he he leaves very so
that you can tell us at least very soon
all right and uh shepard you know he's
he's coaches he's a high note or alumni
i feel like we're ending on a low note
steve
listen we're leaving it to you to end on
a high note because you've got a wreck
okay
wreck baby wreck baby one two three four
i recommend that uh you know if you're
at a loss for conversation
oh gosh you can't make conversations
with recycling head on over to
conversation starters.com what about
capitalized my not a sponsor and if you
want if you've written something out if
you've strung out a whole bunch of stuff
and then you realize that oh god how do
i so many of these words need to be
capitalized four of four capitalized
five words need to be capitalized
let me go to a website to do it this is
the dumbest thing i've ever heard of
okay i'm sorry
capitalizemytitle.com
link thinks you're a good idea
i think
the proof is in the pudding the reason
that you made
your website into conversation
starters.com essentially you know why
because you knew that you had a dumb
idea my wreck now is pudding fine oh eat
more pudding what flavor
chocolate vanilla swirl okay
all right i can i can get down with that
but but get it out of the recyclable
thing and make it yourself don't get it
out of don't get the individual packs so
that creates more waste don't forget get
your tickets to good mythical evening
goodmythicalevening.com a live ticketed
event on september 1st if you can handle
it on moment house if you can handle it
and also hashtag earbiscus let us know
what you think about the rabbit hole
episodes i mean we have fun when we come
in here and go to conversation
starters.com and if you want to weigh in
give us a little voicemail 1-888
earpod one
hey rhett link this is alex from
colorado and i just finished listening
to your podcast episode about your trip
your college guys and i have to say your
assessment on colorado fashion is 100
correct we are always dressed and ready
for anything
the weather here is also
very fickle and it will change so
quickly so we have to be ready to adapt
to the weather glad you had fun i hope
you come back and check out more of what
our beautiful state has to offer
i written link i i just watched the
neighbor and roommate horror stories
when y'all were talking about the uh
bushes
i just absolutely loved uh link being
the night bush boy
i got a really good laugh this morning
thanks guys hi my name is thomas and i
am nine years old and
what happens when a frog parks in an
illegal parking spot
it gets towed
hey in case you missed it we launched a
new collection over at psyc.la
everything we release over there all the
products and apparel change right before
your eyes so check it out and we're
giving you a discount code to use on
your first visit shop psyc.la drop in eb
made you look at check out and enjoy 10
off your whole purchase eb made your
luck
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]